loss of cliff robinson robinson helped  lead the portland trail blazers to two  nba finals appearances in the early 90s  his 18-year career included an all-star  appearance  and the 1993 nba's sixth man of the year  award  the nba family also mourns the loss of  hall of fame coach  lute olson who made a significant impact  on countless current and former  nba players as well as the loss of actor  chadwick boseman  a close friend of the nba who appeared  in iconic movies  such as the jackie robinson biopic 42  and black panther please join us in  observing a moment of silence  in honor of cliff robinson  luke olsen and chadwick boseman  thank you  today's presentation of the national  anthem has been recorded and performed  by  sean hinton  [Music]  uh  [Music]  oh  [Music]  oh  [Music]  you